tonight hi my name is Jenny espero there
and tonight I'm gonna tell you the story
the true story behind a league of their
own
cheers Cheers we start a story with
Marge and Helen Callahan two sisters
growing up in Vancouver Canada these two
women are natural athletes they're
soaking stick and tight and they're like
a Yowie joined a fastpitch softball
league together okay so now we're gonna
fast forward a little bit to 1942 we're
in the midst of World War two and the
draft is going on full force now this
guy the Commissioner of the MLB Kenesaw
Mountain Landis
I hate say my name he's like I'm the new
morover Commissioner of Major League and
minor league baseball and while I'm
calling the shots everyone's being
drafted into World War two so music okay
I my big-boy pants on I'm I figure this
out because Philip K Wrigley Philip key
Wrigley is like Chomp Chomp hello and
Kenesaw Mountain Landis is like all my
men 3,000 minor league players major
league players are gone no war Gabriel
is like okay
I've got an idea for you we are gonna
capitalize on the popularity of women's
softball badass women and it's like the
40s right that's that's a crazy time to
do this so Philip K Wrigley and his
buddy Ken sells go out scouting all
throughout the Midwest
lo and behold who do they run into but
Helen and Marge Callahan what are they
doing there they are playing fast pitch
softball
in Helen and Marge are like we are
dominating this field Philip and can run
out to this they run out to the field
and they're like you the both of you we
need you both
you got to be on our team and they sign
on the door I had $75 a week so they're
both on the Minneapolis Marion hands
Miller hats so Marg and Helen are like
we're on this team this is in tight
they're playing double headers like a
hundred and fifteen degree weather in
Phillip K Wrigley is like I know how to
sell a product and I need these women to
look like women these chaperones are
like I am going to make sure that their
hair is curl their lipstick is on
there's makeup is fully done their
skirts or ironed before they head out
onto the field
people are full to watch these women in
these adorable dresses play in baseball
like men and Marge Callie and Helen
Callahan are knocking this [ __ ] out of
park women are stealing bases they're
like what's that mother no Phillip K
Wrigley looks like this he's like these
aren't women
peaceful these are baseball players yeah
dude it's so badass
right this is my seventh inning stretch
this is mine
all right let's play ball
yeah okay so 1945 comes right and World
War two is ending Georgia Maggio Ted
Williams the major minor league players
come back and they're like hi everybody
yeah we've been a Wars terrible we're
ready to hit some balls so they they and
ends up fizzling out thirty years passes
and this story is forgotten until 1985
there was a reunion
Helen Callan delays this is harder now
than it was earlier are you still doing
it
Kelly can delay Helens oldest son was
like I'm gonna record this [ __ ] you
website is Kim Carter and all these old
ladies are playing ball like they did
back in the in 40s
Kelly can delay creates a league of
their own documentary it's a huge video
and Penny Marshall sees this documentary
she's like what the I didn't know this
[ __ ] existed history Oh beanie I should
make a movie about this story because
it's important for women of all ages
if it wasn't for a league of our own
nobody would have ever known that women
can throw a ball like in the man
[Music]
[Applause]